[Musique]
je pousse mon cadis entre les
étalages je passe de la crèmerie au
rayon
maquillage dans le fond spécial
promotion soyez belles et sans souci
avec le savon qui
rajunit je pousse mon cadis entre les
étalurs je passe de la charcuterie aux
cabin des
C dans le fond spécial promotion un
bonheur un chez
d'Urre garanti pièces main
d'Urre mais c'est qui qui fait la viande
c'est qui qui fait la viande mais c'est
qui qui fait la viande c'est
qui je pousse mon cadis entre les
rayonage
j'enveloppe mes envies de papier
d'emballage dans le fond spécial
promotion un bonheur au douce
parfum trois amours pour le
prudent mais c'est qui qui fait la
viande
c'est qui qui fait la viande mais c'est
qui qui fait la viande c'est
[Musique]
qui
je pousse mon cadis entre les pierres
tombales je pousse ma faille entre le
bien et le
mal dans le fond spécial promotion tombe
là pour gagner gagner le Paradis
assuré mais c'est qui qui fait la viande
c'est qui qui fait la viande c'est qui
qui fait la viande
c'est
qui qui qui fait la viande qui qui fait
la viande c'est qui qui fait la viande
c'est
[Musique]
qui
garis GIS gison
garnison
[Musique]
GIS
une garnison
garnis une
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
garnis
well I feel just like a
child yeah I feel just like a
child well I feel just like a little
child I feel just like
a from my to my gu I'll
be well I need you to tell me what
to and I need you to help me
my and I need you to come keep me
am and I need you to come shoes down
from my cave to myve I gu I'll always be
a
little
and I need you to walk me to
the and I need you to help me
reach and I need you to please explain
the war and I need you to me
so you
little and I need you to me on
and
[Musique]
make and I need you ton
my SH a and a seat you know I won touch
myood eat from the ro to Flo C little
[Musique]
more and I need you to help me blow my
nose blow my nose and I need you to help
me put put put on my cles and I need
you two F i you where
from being my daddy
[Musique]
to and when I Ste you got smack me till
I cry where don't you stop thear run
Dr I was all the
[Musique]
SK
oo co
Co
[Musique]
Mikono
M
[Musique]
male mal say mikon
V
[Musique]
AD
adya
[Musique]
AB
adya
ad
AB
[Musique]
naletea analetea ni
wa
[Musique]
analetea Nala
anal
e
[Musique]
E
a
[Musique]
nen
le
n
[Musique]
nen
tr
[Musique]
ire
ye
ye ye
[Musique]
acarici mi
uo suave
murmo tu
sus r la
vi si tus ojos negros meen
mirar y si mi
[Musique]
arore como un
cantar
toeta
[Musique]
mi el
día que me
[Musique]
quieras la
RA
queanana
se vestirá de
fiesta con su mejor
color y al viento las
campanas dirán que ya eres
mí y locas la
fontanas me
contarán su
amor
la noche que me
quieras des Azul el
cielo las estrellas
celosas no
mirarán
pasar y un Rayo
miterioso
paraáen tu
fero
lnaosa
[Musique]
consuel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai quelques VI mais je suis pe plus
clean que le palais de la justice si je
fais des vieux eau faut pas que ça soit
à l'hospice profite même si je sais que
ça glisse avec le vent comme complice
avec le vent comme
complice avec le vent comme complice
complice avec le vent comme je
mademoiselle mesdames messieur c'est
Johnny fou le feu Johnny s'en fout
Johnny veut sa part de soleil comme vous
l'animal à de PTE qui prend ses marches
de
Bou TR j'ai quelques rêves un peu fous
j'aimerais causer avec les animaux comme
je le fais avec vous faire de la gratte
comme Dango Jimmy et Paco pour ça je
rêve tôt dès le matin j'y crois fort
avanttitège paraî qu'on a rien sans rien
si savoir sans privilège on sait trop
pour rien puis je donne ma langue au
chacousin bien que je sois chelou un peu
vin pas voyou même pas méchamp pourou
dessous tout juste innocent comme vous
même si comme vous parfois j'ai un peu
de mal à aller jusqu'au bout j'avoue
jeenny plus d'une fois j'ai pr m jambes
à mon coup c'est fou je suis plus fort
pour ramasser pour donner des coups à
force d'en prendre Johnny vous voyez
flou j'ai quelques vis mais jeis piss
plus CIN que le palais de la justice si
je fais des vieux faut pas que ça soit à
l'hospice profite même si c'est que ça
glisse avec le vent comme complice avec
le vent comme
complice avec le vent comme complice
avec le vent comme
complice avec le vent comme Johnny belle
Guu Johnny ferme la grande gueule Johnny
dans le V je sais que tu es seul ma
gueule Johnny B
Joh pas c'est pas ce qu' la dérange tu
sois poli ou non dans le fond je vois
pas ce que ça change Johnny pourquoi tu
te con r la trône grand coup de pon
Johnny s Vergon Johnny savait mais plus
et puis tuas trop bu Johnny tu continues
comme ça ils vont bouffer tout cru
Johnny
aim de Johnny savait pas vraiment ce que
je foutais là mais il y avait du TA
alors j'y suis allé voilà Johnny je
voulais un peu de grisb et puis rentrer
chez moi mais et les années ont dit ça
se passera pas comme ça Johnny le
fossoyur poète à 16 he Johnny le petit
menteur et sa sœur qui vend des fleurs
Johnny tu t'es pas levé ce matin pour
aller à la messe tu as préféré rejoindre
Johnny tuas posé suite caresse Johnny tu
en as déjà trop dit fou quand il en
vitesse avant que le BIT ne te blesse
johnny c'est lui Johnny c'est vous
johnny c'est moi faites bien gaffe à
vous et m'oubliez pas j'ai quelques VI
mais je suis piss plus clean que le
palais de la justice si je fais des
vieux eau faut pas que ça soit à
l'hospice profite même si je sais que ça
glisse avec le vent comme complice avec
le vent comme
complice avec le vent comme complice
avec le vent comme
complice avec le vent comme
[Musique]
complice
à la mairie moi j'aimais lire dans la
brique trois mots
magiques qui nous promettit en cas de
malheur du bom au
cœur mais quel quelque chose m'a fait
dire mais ils ont oublié de mettre les
guillemet oui quelque chose m'a fait
dire mais est-ce que c'est moi qui doit
mettre les Guillet 3 mots accrocher
qu'est-ce que ça pèse quand on n pas
l'air ou quand on n pas le pèse TR mots
accrochés qui nous ont
[Musique]
fâchés
à la mosquée comme à l'église c'est tout
kiff ces demoiselles juge à la couleur
du pif
elle te promettent un truc meilleur un
truc meilleur mais c'est ailleurs ces
jolies filles ont be s'y mettre à trois
il faut les aimer mais sans les toucher
du doigt alors autant qu'on est la
praise il faut qu'on soit sourd autant
qu'on se taise alors autant qu'on est la
braise oh je suis français pas du pipo
mais sang que je suis franc là jusqu'à
mon accent je suis franc et c'est dit
tout en passant je suis français par le
sol et pas par le sang je suis français
pas du pipo mes sang que je suis Fran là
jusqu'à mon accent et je suis franc et
c'est dit tout en passant je suis
français par le sol et pas par le sang
au marché du palais il y avait un beau
dessin qui disait gar à tous les
assassins et quelque chose m'a fait dire
quoi posé dessus on pèse pas le même
poids c'est toujours du même côté
qu'elle penche cette balance et la
semaine et le dimanche alors autant
qu'on est la braise s'il faut qu'on soit
sour autant qu'on se taise alors autant
qu'on est la
braise oh je suis français pas du pipo M
S que je suis franc là jusqu'à mon
accent je suis franc et c'est du tout en
passant je suis français par le sol et
pas par le sang je suis français pas du
PIP au m sang que je suis franc là
jusqu'à mon accent et je suis FR et
c'est du tout en passant je suis
français par le sol et pas par le
[Musique]
S